i've actually started to do blood work
i'm 39 years old and i have some things
that are going on and i'm like i feel
like i need to get my blood checked so
i've actually i have i've had three
blood draws now and just to kind of
figure out things that are going on and
other do you recommend that that be
something that people do regularly only
when they need it and like what kind of
tests are good to know
i mean it depe testing is always for you
know desired outcome right so i think
first and foremost you should always
have an annual hormone panel when you go
to the gynecologist now
they may not want to cover that that's
the problem right so but i do think we
should be annually checking
how we're doing with estrogen
progesterone thyroid all of those things
yeah since we can't often get that
covered by insurance
especially when there are no problems um
i think that that's where at home
hormone testing is becoming a really
great solution
um you know where you can you know by
using either dried urine analysis saliva
or even blood spot really get some
accurate information
over time and that's the thing if you're
testing your hormones
for let's just say to see how your cycle
is doing as a whole and keep in mind
the american college of this
obstetricians and gynecologists decreed
that your cycle now be considered a
fifth vital sign right
so it that means you want to take it as
seriously as you take an elevated
temperature right
so if that's the case then we should be
evaluating our cycle as a whole over the
course of a month so a single blood test
is like a polaroid picture
it's a snapshot of what the hormone
concentrations are in your blood at that
particular moment of the blood draw
which is less relevant if you're trying
to see well how is my estrogen changing
throughout the month and what are my
progesterone levels during my ludial
phase it's not as helpful of a test
so that's where some other testing that
you can do at home is more valuable
if you're doing some baseline testing
day three testing for fertility kind of
evaluation
that's a very good thing to do although
we now know that amh levels i think
women get really concerned about their
amh levels we know for sure that that
doesn't necessarily dictate
how much fertile time you have left
it's about egg quality not egg quantity
it turns out
so don't be overly concerned about that
number if that number is you know not
what you think it should be the better
number to be looking at
is follicular stimulating hormone right
if your fsh numbers are too high
then that that's a better indication if
you're let's say looking through the
lens of how are you doing from a
fertility point of view that's a much
better indicator of are you prematurely
hormonally aging
because if you're aging too quickly that
fsh number is going to go up and up and
up earlier
fsh you know is the hormone that
stimulates the ovulation process right
if it gets too high the body stops
ovulating this is the whole process of
perimenopause now it begins at 35
for every woman
okay but that's not anything to be
alarmed about think about it again
puberty begins at in the brain it begins
around 9 10 but it doesn't complete
until age 22
the whole journey of pubescence right
same thing with perimenopause it's a
it's a 10 to 15 year journey easily
so it's good that it starts early and it
takes a long time you tend to not notice
any irregularities in ovulation and
menstruation until your mid to late 40s
if you're taking care of your cycle
which is another reason why the cycle
sinking method that i created which
supports your cyclical hormones right in
your reproductive years is such an
important thing for you to do if you're
if you know you're going to be delaying
your motherhood journey you want to
preserve and protect your um cycle as as
optimally as possible and the cycle
sinking method is really the best way
for you to do that
and that way you can prolong slow down
that premature aging make sure that
you're not having a quick rise in your
fsh labels that would be an indicator a
much better indicator of you know where
you are with fertility than the amhp so
although you know it's an important data
point but i would argue that fsh is more
relevant
what are your thoughts on um ivf i and
what that does to the body i did it when
i was 33
and
i don't know i feel like in my in my
intuition i can go
i think everything changed i i mean like
i just think that like it was such a
roller coaster
for
five four or five weeks that you know
and it also was the really the thing
that happened it's in the end the name
of the podcast is pretty intense because
i wrote a book called pretty intense and
the reason why the book came was because
i did that and then i gained five pounds
just because of hormones and i was like
oh my god hormones are real oh my god
it's not just like eat less it's a real
thing
um so uh you know because i know that
this is something that you know i mean i
used it for my own reason because i
wasn't in a situation where i knew my
future so yeah i did it proactively uh
but there are people doing it um in the
moment to try and get pregnant as
quickly as possible because it's it's um
it's something that is hard for them so
you know what are what are what is
really happening to the body and then
perhaps you know for those who have done
it like what's the what's the sort of
fallout or the repercussions of the
recovery
um uh after that much uh
that much control from the outside
instead of the inside
listen i think it is an extraordinary
thing that we have assisted reproductive
technology because
unfortunately we're in a situation where
due to
um xenoestrogenic you know chemical
exposure both the fertility rates of men
and women are really on the decline so
this is not just a problem that's
affecting women you know for example the
gl did you know the global sperm count
for men is down 50 percent
across the board i mean this makes like
population such a crap yeah okay keep
going so it's an interesting thing
and so you know i'm i am
super
happy
whenever there's technology that helps
people medical technology i mean i think
it is a really good thing fundamentally
um so that's sort of my high level
stance um
what i think
that we could be doing a better job with
is is you know i'm it's going to sound
like i'm repeating myself we should be
doing a better job of educating women
about
how they need to be interacting with
their hormonal self-care
so that they don't end up needing the
most extreme versions of these
interventions right because it's like
cooking you know i like to cook i'm you
know it's like a thing i do for
relaxation and it's kind of like you
know you can always add more salt
to the soup but once you put it in you
really you know it's there you can't
really take it out so similarly if
you're gonna think about you know being
on an ivf journey
it's more it's is it not more logical to
think okay gee
all right maybe i've spent the past 15
years on a hormone suppressant
uh medication like birth control right
which shuts off your hormones okay so
i've done that
so that's not optimal
i've had all 15 years of depleting key
micronutrients that support my hormones
and fertility got to do something about
that i've also led a pretty stressful
life where i've been burning the candle
at both ends drinking coffee um
having a lot of you know alcohol to calm
down
um yeah i eat the same kind of
restricted calorie diet every day and i
do like hit workouts every day because
i'm worried about getting and are you
talking about me
you and everybody else sister right this
is this is what happens when we're not
given the right blueprint or the map to
follow
and then you wonder why there's so much
struggle around conception because
conception takes place in the body when
the ecosystem is abundant nutrient rich
hormonally balanced when the nervous
system is you know calm and at
equilibrium when the immune system is
functioning when there's no inflammation
this is what the body wants from a
conception point of view because it is
not just sperm meets egg drop it into
the uterus it's there's a whole
immunological response between the
endometrium the egg the female body
itself it means it's a really delicate
process
so you have to come into it like ripe
like a peach you know what i mean from a
from a micronutrient point of view from
a health point of view if you roll into
that process
super depleted having two decades of not
taking care of your hormones yeah you
might need more aggressive interventions
which is neither a good nor a bad thing
it's just more let's understand how you
ended up in that place and then you can
make a decision about what is reasonable
for you
if you're out of time
you know and the only path forward are
aggressive interventions then that's a
reasonable thing to do if you have more
time and you've acknowledged that you've
done everything that kind of interrupts
your body's ability to be optimally
fertile then take some time to rectify
that